الطائرات على ارتفاع لا تسقط من
السماء، وهذه نقطة البداية لأي
نقاش حول ما حدث
لهذه الطائرة في المسار الطبيعي
للطيران، بمجرد أن تصل الطائرة إلى
ارتفاعها، تكون في الجزء الأكثر أمانًا من
رحلتها، ولا يتم الضغط على المحركات
إنها تتحرك كما كانت بالفعل هذه
الطائرة عند مستوى الطيران
28513. لذلك عليك أن تسأل نفسك ما هو
نوع الحادث
المتعمد أو غير ذلك من شأنه أن يتسبب في
سقوط الطائرة فجأة في السماء وبمجرد انتقالك إلى
هذا المجال  أنت في
منطقة مختلفة تمامًا لأنك تتحدث حرفيًا
عن بعض الأشياء فقط، وتتحدث
عن الفشل التام للهيكل الجوي
للطائرة
وفقًا لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية الروسية، وهي طائرة
مطابقة لوصف يفغيني
باجوسيين وهو  تحطمت طائرة نفاثة من طراز إمبراير
شمال غرب موسكو
وهذا هو الفيديو الذي جاء أه
من منطقة تافاري حيث يمكنك رؤية
هذه الطائرة وهي تسقط للتو من السماء
ووفقًا للملاحظات يبدو أنها
تفتقد جناحًا  أريد
إحضار العقيد المتقاعد في القوات الجوية سيدريك لايتون
أه سيدريك، 26 عامًا من العمل
في القوات الجوية بما في ذلك الكثير من ذلك
كضابط مخابرات، ما هي
الأسئلة التي أثيرت بالنسبة لك عندما كنت
تنظر إلى الصور غير العادية
التي نتلقاها هنا
وهذه التفاصيل التي نتعلمها،
نعم بريانا، أعتقد أن أحد
الأشياء الأساسية هو أنك تعرف نوع
الانفجار الذي كان، هل كان هذا شيئًا آه كما
تعلم هل كان ناجمًا عن
صاروخ مثل آه كما تعلم مع mh17
أم كان شيئًا ما  لقد حدث
انفجار على متن الطائرة، كما تعلم شيئًا
كان من الممكن أن يكون قد نتج عن قنبلة
تم وضعها أو الطائرة، لذا أه هذا
شيء أه كما تعلم أنه ليس
واضحًا تمامًا بعد بناءً على ما رأيناه حتى
الآن إذا كان صحيحًا أن وينج كان  مفقود
أه عندما سقطت الطائرة من الواضح أن
الطائرة ليست صالحة للطيران في هذا
الموقف وعندما تهبط بهذه الطريقة
أه تعلم أنه ليس
شيئًا يمكنه الطيران أه
بنمط عادي وهذا ما تعلمه سيفسر
مسار الطائرة  الطائرة كما هي آه كما
تعلم كانت آه تتحرك بسرعة
نحو الأرض آه لذا فأنت تعلم أن هذه
هي الأشياء الرئيسية ومن ثم تعرف
المزيد آه من منظور أوسع آه كما تعلم عند
النظر إلى هذا الصراع على السلطة آه
تعلم أننا أنا  فكر بوضوح في رؤية
إنتاج بوتين
لعناصر فاغنر، كل هذه الأشياء تصبح
عنصرًا أساسيًا في ما يتعين علينا تحليله
هنا لماذا حدث هذا، ثم أيضًا إذا
كان بريجوسيان في الواقع على متن هذه
الطائرة إذا كان قيادته المعارة على
متن الطائرة، فستحصل على  إلى وضع
أه فيه القضاء على
مجموعة فاغنر هو أمر
قادم بشكل واضح في هذه الحالة وأعتقد
أه تعلم أننا نرى نتائج
ذلك الجهد أه من بوتين أه للتخلص من
أي معارضة من على الأقل  هذا القطاع
في أه، كما تعلم مجتمعه الروسي، لقد
كنت تتوقع قبل أسبوعين فقط
أن
يموت باغوسيان أو أنه سيكون هناك
انقلاب ثانٍ بحلول نهاية العام، ما
رأيك في التوقيت هنا إذا كان
بوتين  كان وراء هذا البئر
أعني مرة أخرى على افتراض أن
بوتين كان وراء ذلك ويبدو أنه
لا توجد قوة في روسيا يمكنها أن
تفعل هذا أه خارج
تصريح بوتين أه لكل عرض ثم أه
السؤال الوحيد هو لماذا حدث ذلك بهذه السرعة
أعني السبب الذي جعلنا نناقش في هذا البرنامج
منذ بضعة أسابيع أن
بوتين يجب أن ينتقم ويجب أن يزيل
الحيطة المحايدة أه بمجرد أن وصفهم
بالتاجر لأنه بخلاف ذلك
سيفقد القدرة على الحكم بقسوة لا
ترحم المشكلة الوحيدة في
التوقيت هي ذلك  لقد حدث ذلك
بسرعة كبيرة جدًا، وحدث قبل أن يتمكن بوتين من
تدمير تأثير البريجوسيان في
أفريقيا بشكل أساسي، وتدمير تأثير
التطهير على قوات فاغنر المتبقية،
وأعتقد أن هذا يتعلق تمامًا
بأفريقيا، أعني في الأسبوع الماضي الذي
رأيناه  الكثير من التصعيد في القتال العميق
بين وزارة الدفاع
وبوتين والكرملين أه من جهة
والبرغوسيان من جهة أخرى على
جوجل احتفظت بالسيطرة على بعض
الأسواق الأكثر ربحًا أه في أفريقيا على
مالي على جمهورية أفريقيا الوسطى في
الواقع  كان الاحتياط في أفريقيا في
اليومين الماضيين وكان في طريق العودة من
أفريقيا محاولاً الاحتفاظ بالسيطرة على
مالي وعدم التنازل عن السيطرة
لوزارة الدفاع وأعتقد أن
هذا التصعيد في الاهتمام
بأفريقيا هو الذي عجل بهذا الإجراء.
ضد بريجوسيا
الأجنبية